quick answers as fast as you can okay  threes there it's not Barbara Walters  don't worry I'll hate emojis who hates  emojis but with a little poop so you  like the prowl fine I don't oh my gosh  what we listened to last night I was  with some friends who are singing at the  top of their lungs a lot of Neil Young  oh yeah good Canadian boy nice  Thank You her Malibu I love my home yes  I don't watch TV either I don't watch it  on TV but I'm supposed to start this is  so I'm brothers hey can you go to uni  air can judge to my son have you landed  there we go all right yeah this is a  question we ask everyone rose a rose a  wine and also you know rosette bubbles  fruit rozay is a dance okay and this is  my favorite so we're gonna go from here  we're going to make more